foreign
think of a situation where a person a
with headsets wants to get an iPad and a
person B wants to get a headset with an
iPad
so to reach out to each other easily
they go to a gadget shop and sell their
products let's shop
and buy the other products headset for
person B and iPad of a person name there
itself
well similar to the scouted shop uni
swap also serves as a platform where you
can exchange ethereum coin with any
ethereum token just by paying a very
small fee and without any intermediaries
hey everyone welcome to this new video
of Simply learn on what is uni swap that
will help you understand all the
necessary concepts related to UNI swap
so stay tuned also before moving ahead
please do subscribe to my YouTube
channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update from Simply run well in
this video you are going to explore what
is uni Spa
and what is you and I then you will
learn about its governance process
how does uni swap work
following that you will know how to use
uniform and what are the pros and cons
of using sperm and at last you will know
how to invest in uni swap
let's get started with what uniswap is
uni swap is a completely different kind
of exchange that uses an automatic
liquidity protocol a latest trading
methodology that is fully decentralized
meaning it isn't owned and run by a
single entity
it enables peer-to-peer Market making
uni swap is also a cryptocurrency whose
symbol is uni it enables users to trade
cryptocurrencies without any involvement
with a centralized third party the
ethereum platform serves as the
foundation for the units for black
blockchain
which is controlled by uni owners and is
completely open source meaning that
anyone can view and contribute to the
blockchain school
basically works on supply and demand
mechanisms let me show you how
on uni swap when you exchange your
ethereum they give you a fair market
value of the basic ethereum token
now after you are done the price of
basic ethereum token Rises because there
are less of them since you bought it and
price of ethereum drops because there is
more of it since you sold it now whoever
comes next will have to buy the basic
ethereum token at a higher price or sell
some ethereum at a higher price
this is actually done to even out the
liquidity pool so that uni swap has an
even amount of ethereum and on the basic
Italian tokens
so now that you know what unispope is
let me take you through what you and I
is
basically the uni swap token makes it
possible for the community and
stakeholders to own and actively manage
the protocol by voting on important
protocol updates and development
projects
through an orange and governance process
uni holders run this protocol therefore
anyone can earn you and I but agreeing
to not sell or trade their crypto
Holdings
this brings the question of what is
uniswap governance process is so the
first step is the temperature check
procedure determines whether there is
enough motor to change the current
situation
a majority vote with a 25k uni yes vote
threshold prevails at the end of the two
days now the subject is closed on the
governance side if the temperature check
does not suggest that there should be a
change from the current situation then
if it does suggest any changes then it
is pushed to Second Step that is the
consensus check
now the consensus check procedure
develops a formal conversation
surrounding a proposal and takes into
account feedback from the temperature
check another off-chain vote follows
consensus check and a majority vote with
the 50k uni yes vote threshold prevails
after 5 days
and then comes the last step that is the
governance proposal the governance
process ends with the governance
proposal The Proposal comes with a 19
executable code and should take into
account the consensus check suggestions
a delegate must have a minimum balance
of 2 million uni in order to submit an
on-chean governance proposal a majority
vote with a 40 m uni yes whole threshold
wins after a seven day voting period now
that you know the mechanism of of the
unisport platform let me tell you how it
actually works the uni swap platform
enables the decentralized trade of
numerous different digital assets using
smart contracts big on the blockchain
through liquidity pools which utilize
smart contracts to automatically
rebalance themselves up to each trade
pairs or digital assets are exchanged
uni swap is powered by two smart
contracts The Exchange contract and the
factory contract
these automatic computer programs made
to carry out particular tasks when
certain criterias are met in this case
the factory smart contract is used to
add new tokens to platform while the
exchange contract handles all token
swaps or trades
on the new uni swap version 2 platform
any erc20 base token can be exchanged
for another well this covers all the
internal functionality of uniswap so
moving on you will learn how to use
uniswa
well you only need an ethereum wallet
like coinbase wallet and a small amount
of eth which you'll need to pay for gas
fees in order to utilize unisform you
can access
app.unispirp.org to begin exchanging
tokens or provide liquidity by using the
app browser included in the coinbase
wallet mobile application or its desktop
browse extension moving on let me tell
you about some of its pros and cons
well it enables to decentralize exchange
of many digital assets but it only
supports the exchange of ethereum
compatible cryptocurrencies
second smart contracts enable asset
trading that may be cheaper and more
efficient but it still uses proof of
work which is an energy and resource
intensive process
uni swap users can earn you and I
agreeing to not sell or trade their
cryptocurrency Holdings but users must
do an eth to pay transaction processing
fee for
decentralized governance of the uniswap
platform enables anyone to participate
however using a decentralized exchange
requires a compatible self-hosted wallet
so now comes the most important question
of this whole discussion
how can you invest in units work
by getting you and I you can make an
investment in uni swap using a
centralized cryptocurrency exchange like
coinbase or Kraken is the simplest way
to purchase uni
another coin like ethereum can be used
to buy you and I on the universe
platform when this was all about uni
soil I hope you enjoyed this video and
found it interesting and informative if
you like this video then please do share
it with your friends and drop a thumbs
up if you have any questions related to
this video then please feel free to ask
away in the comment section our team
will reach out to you as soon as
possible
thank you for watching this video and
keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here